est-ce qu'il s'est passé dans l'émission
alors tu as fait l'émission euh de Léa
Salamé Christophe Dechavanne la semaine
dernière et c'est vrai qu'il y a une
séquence qui a été coupée avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon puisque alors si on n'était
pas en direct qu'elle a très bien marché
d'ailleurs l'émission vous les
retrouverez cette semaine mais qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
alors j'arrive je vois ma loge tac tac
tac on dit bon voilà avec Mélenchon
comme ça comme ça comme ça moi je
parlais c'est avec qui me disent comme
ça personne va me dire qu'est-ce que
j'ai à dire et j'avais envie de me le
faire Mélenchon moi vraiment vraiment
j'avais une chère parce que c'est de
dire aux gens les pauvres et tu vis pas
comme un pauvre tu ne vois pas la
souffrance parce que lui il est marrant
lui crie crie quand lui pose une vraie
question il crie seulement il répond pas
à la question donc j'ai dit ok je vais
me le faire j'adore ce mec là en plus la
vérité il parle beaucoup puis d'un seul
coup je le vois en face avec tous ces
politiciens derrière et puis d'un seul
coup je le vois comme ça des mecs c'est
marqué donc je suis fier moi tu sais que
j'avance pas comme ça je dis à Julie
Madar tu as vu même lui il me connaît tu
as compris donc j'arrive comme ça il
vient il vient pompier rarement et je
fais ça et j'avance d'un seul coup que
j'arrive je dois être dans l'émission au
début et Mélenchon il veut pas
Mélenchon il veut pas que je sois dans
le plateau et je dis à
la personne qui vient me voir je dis
c'est lui qui commande l'émission mais
dis non mais il veut pas je dis mais
c'est lui qui l'attend je comprends pas
j'arrive pas à comprendre c'est où moi
ou lui ou tous les deux mondes nous
parler j'ai dit bon allez ok prêt d'un
seul coup Julie Madar m'a dit rentre
dans le plateau sans être invité et puis
vas-y parce qu'il a pas attendu du
plateau et et j'ai dit mais attends je
suis pas populaire je suis une star
quand même je veux pas rentrer dans le
plateau comme ça j'ai un peu frimé j'ai
dit non et puis un jour je me le ferai
je te le promets que je me le paye
mérite vous n'êtes pas parlé non pas du
tout et en plus de ça je sais pas si tu
as vu le plateau quand je suis sorti
parce qu'ils l'ont coupé ils l'ont coupé
trois fois il devait sortir vers moi et
à chaque fois il retenait pour qu'il
sort de l'autre côté mais moi j'ai dit
si il sort vers moi je me le fais tout
de suite et ils l'ont j'ai pas trouvé
l'ancien et puis bon ils ont coupé
parler du tout mais il voulait pas
d'abord ils ont changé de loge et
qu'est-ce que tu voulais lui dire mais
il lui dira en vrai mais il lui dira
un mec qui veut diriger la France il y a
pas de problème mais quand tu dirige la
France et puis tu as une société qui est
un parti tu es en train de couler que ta
femme te facture tu as été ta publicité
enfant tu as comment on appelle ça
campagne et puis tu fais ta femme peut
te facturer qu'est-ce qu'elle veut et
puis tant que tu l'oseille des pauvres
des syndicalistes tu peux pas me dire
que tu peux représenter la France quand
même c'est pas possible donc il y a des
gens qui ne peuvent pas représenter la
France qui parle pour rien de dire le de
dire je t'aime et de ne pas donner de
preuve d'amour à ta femme ça vaut 0
parce que tu peux le dire toute la
journée et lui de dire le pauvre et il a
toujours mangé à sa fin c'est pas
possible il y a un qui va pas avec
l'autre voilà et j'ai envie de lui dire
et j'ai envie de dire arrête
arrête-toi de parler dans le vent tu
sais quand tu viens il est devant les il
a une fausse facture il cri cri vole pas
qui rentre arrête qui dit qu'il est pour
les citoyens les flics sont comme les
citoyens ils ont un ordre ils
travaillent ils vont aller chercher une
perquisition ils ont le droit d'y aller
va pas crier parce qu'il y a les caméras
et puis en plus l'autre qui a pris une
carte dans la gueule à sa femme mais
pourquoi pourquoi il va le défendre
pourquoi il va le défendre moi je sais
pourquoi le défend c'est parce que
l'autre il lui a dit si tu me défends
pas dans ce coup là je dis tout ce qui
s'est passé mort pour mort on est mort
voilà
[Applaudissements]